The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
SPEAKER 1: So the schedule
for today-- once again,
another one of those
one hour lecture,
two hour group work things.
We've got a guest
lecturer today.
We're got Luigi, here, to talk
to us about art and artists,
especially when it comes
to games and, particularly,
visual artists.
Yeah?
LUIGI GUATIERI: Yes.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah,
so visual artists
when it comes to
game development.
After his lecture,
and after Q&A, we
don't have any scheduled
play tests today,
but we do have a
couple of guests here
who have some really good
experience making games.
So if you'd like to set aside
10 to 15 minutes per team,
have a person come
and play your game,
I'd highly recommend
taking advantage of it.
I mean, it all depends,
I think, on what state
your games are in.
I do want to know that.
How many teams are
now working in what
is going to be their final
development environment.
So if you're working
in Phaser, you're
building in Phaser now, if
you're working in Unity,
you're working in Unity now.
Looks like one team,
two teams, three teams--
is that two different
teams over there?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
SPEAKER 1: Here.
OK, great.
So everybody's
pretty much working
in a development environment.
Great.
Cool.
So like I said, as
it says on Stellar,
Wednesday we're going to have
a play test at 3 o'clock.
So at 3 o'clock we're going
to have a guest class come in
to play your games.
We'll do a play test,
just like we've always
been doing play tests.
And then before that, I'm going
to be giving a talk on fiction
and story for your games.
And in between there will be
time for you to meet your teams
and set up for your play tests.
LUIGI GUATIERI: Cool,
artists and games.
And So this talk's going
to be about what artists
do in games, how
to find artists,
how to work with artists,
how artists are involved
in game development,
the different roles that
are assigned to them.
I'm going to be talking
from the independent games
perspective, so smaller
teams, because that's
sort of my background and
my experience with games.
But I will talk a little bit
about the diversification
of artists' roles
in bigger studios.
First, who am I?
I'm me.
I'm this dude in the corner.
My name's Luigi Guatieri.
I'm a local Boston
indie artist, when
it comes to games at least--
no so much comics anymore.
Yeah, so I work with a lot
of teams in Boston developing
games.
Since so few of these developers
know a lot of artists,
I get to work on a lot
of different projects,
because they don't have a
lot of people to turn to.
And I'll go into
that in a little bit.
Sort of games I've
developed in the past-- I
worked on Girls Like
Robots with Ziba Scott--
up there-- which was
published by Adult Swim, iOS.
And he likes to tout it
as the 13th best rated
iOS game of 2012.
I don't really care
about that statistic,
but I'll mention it anyways.
I worked on The
Counting Kingdom which
Jenna Hoffstein, which
is actually coming out
this week on iOS.
So if you have
kids, please buy it.
If you're not a
kid, buy it anyways.
I've been working on Elegy for
a Dead World, also with Ziba,
and, as a partnership,
with Dejobaan Studios,
which had a successful
Kickstarter so
if anybody backed it in
here, that was great.
But if none of you did,
then sucks to be you.
All right, that's
sort of my summary.
I'm not going to show my
portfolio, or anything.
But let's get into it.
So you need an artist.
You're a programmer, or a
designer, or a sound guy,
and you can't draw for crap.
You think you can
be like, oh no.
I'll just wing the art.
It'll be fine.
I'll release my game.
No, don't, do that.
Get an artist.
Artists make games look pretty.
Artists make games
more immersive.
Artists take a player
who-- maybe you
have the most amazing game
mechanics in the game, sort
of like a dwarf fortress or
something, which turns away so
many people because
of how ugly it is.
No, you need artists.
Artists make your game
better, more interesting,
even objectively better
in a lot of ways--
if you get the right
artist, of course.
It also makes something
you're proud of looking at,
and proud of showing
off at shows.
When you have your
booth at PAX and you've
got all the AAA studios around,
all the high-end indies,
and then there's you with
blocks that hit each other,
you're going to be kind of
disappointed in yourself.
But cool.
What kind of artist do you need?
But of course, that depends
on what kind of game
you're making.
Obviously, here I
have just doodled
out a few different styles.
Style's a big part
of art for games.
But of course, there's different
roles and different kinds
of artists in the world.
I'm sure a lot of this
will be redundant to any
of those who really
like games, but I'm
going to go over it anyways.
Obviously, in big
studios you have
a lot of very specific
roles for artists.
This is a character artist,
environment artist, texture
artist, this is the animator.
But when it comes
to indie studios,
I'm the guy who does everything.
I do the concept
art, the 2D assets.
I do the promotional material.
I do the graphic design.
I do the logo design.
I make trailers.
Because usually indie
studios don't have the funds.
They don't have the
ability, or the time,
and/or the resources to
get more than one artist,
so it sort of comes
down to the one guy.
But sort of going to go through
the different kinds of art
that are typically
done in games.
I'm going to break it down
to their specific roles.
And I'll talk about-- I'll be
showing mostly my work here.
I'll sort of break it down to
the different kinds of art,
and the different kinds of
artists that work on these.
So first is a swath of
indie games that are 2D now.
Used to be that
retro games were 2D.
And then older games before
polygons and all such things
were all 2-dimensionals--
2-dimension.
So 2D makes up
[? like-- ?] illustrators,
graphic designers, concept
artists, sprite artists,
texture artists, 2D
animators, UI designers--
it is a large field.
Again, with indie developers,
it's easy to go 2D,
because you don't have
to worry about 3D,
which takes a lot more time.
So this is sort of some 2D
assets from a prototype that I
worked on a while back, but
this is sort of [? my old ?]
[? end ?] game stuff.
Of course, the first part of
2D art, which also pertains
to 3D art, and at
bigger studios they
have specific roles for this.
This is concept art.
Concept art is far my favorite
part of pre-production,
at least, in terms of you get to
take what the programmer wants,
and actually make it look like
what they think in their head
it's supposed to look like.
They'll come to you
with a crappy pencil
sketch on some paper, and be
like, here I've got a knight,
and he's on a mountain,
and he's fighting a dragon.
And I'll be like, this doesn't
look anything like that,
but I know exactly what
you're talking about.
And he's like, I'm feeling red!
I want red!
And they just took like
a Sharpie or something,
and just scribbled all
over the piece of paper.
So I'm like, all
right, I got that.
Give me like a day,
and I'll come back,
and then you'll
have this painting
of a knight fighting a dragon.
And the [? programmer's ?]
like, yes!
That's exactly what I
drew on my piece of paper.
It isn't, but you
let them have that.
It makes them feel better.
So concept art is definitely
for both 2D and 3D.
You need to know
what your game is
going to look like
before you dive straight
into it-- into the visuals
and even some of the design,
before you have a
clear idea of what
the game's going to look like.
If you have no idea what
the game is going to look
like, and you already
have an artist,
and you've made this
amazing prototype.
And you're like look, just swap
out my art and put yours in.
That's not always going to work.
There's a lot of
design decisions
you have to make
around the art--
how the characters contrast
from the environment, how
the environments will animate,
how the environments will
disappear into the mist, or
how this sort of UI will work.
These are all things
that it's really good
to have an artist's eye
on as early as possible.
It also gives a sort of
visual Bible for the game.
Concept art helps-- the artist
draws it, and then hands it out
to the rest of the
team, and like, this
is what we're aiming for.
In a big studio, you would
have the concept artist would
hand that off to the 3D
artists or the other 2D
artists, the animator, the
modelers, texture artists,
and say, look, this is
what we're aiming for.
This is what I want
the final product
to look as close as possible to.
But of course, if
you're making 2D games,
you go into 2D assets.
This is a screenshot,
or an early screenshot,
from Elegy for a Dead World.
So with this, I sort of
made the concept art,
cut it up, and stuck
it in the game.
That's a really basic
way of making 2D art.
I have one with this
sort of painterly style
that I decided to go
with the concept art.
I made a painting.
I said this is the style
that we're aiming for.
So I cut it up and
put it in the game.
And now you can move
around when things happen,
and you can explore
this piece of art.
2D assets are part of--
Illustration, it's more of a old
school term, especially when it
comes to games now.
People don't think of
it illustration so much,
but illustration is used
for promotional art,
for advertising the game,
for inspiring your team,
for websites, for
trying to solidify
your game into like a poster,
or an image, or a banner.
So many games are
sold on Steam now
with just a tiny little
banner that you click on,
then you get a little
slightly bigger banner,
and then maybe a
game-play video.
So much of that first click,
like making that person go,
oh that tiny little banner
looks kind of interesting.
Let me click on it-- is
such a crucial point,
especially if you haven't done
your job marketing, that you
need to have illustrations
and promotional art,
and posters, and graphic design.
And that goes under the
Illustrator sort of dome.
In a big studio, they'd usually
have the concept art also
be the illustrations
a lot of the time,
but usually the concept
artists are very proficient,
because they have to be fast.
And they also make the
illustrations for a game.
Obviously as an indie, you're
making the illustrations too.
UI design-- this is like in
between three different facets.
You got design, illustration,
and graphic design.
Graphic design, I mean,
by like sort of logos,
and making things more
readable to users,
but that sort of goes
into game design in terms
of how the UI is going to work.
And then you also need
a graphic designer
to actually make it look good.
This is a big part of
2D design-- obviously,
it's in 2D games,
but usually UI's
flat, because you're dealing
with buttons and menus
and HUD overlays.
So that's sort of a weird
intersection between all three
of these facets, where it'd
sort of have to be usable,
has to make sense in
the game design world,
and it has to look good.
Let's jump into 3D.
3D is the more complicated
side of the art.
Painting a picture doesn't
take me a very long time,
but making a 3D model
takes much longer time,
especially if it's
highly detailed
or needs a lot of
texturing, or I
need to make it work in a
very specific type of game.
There's a reason a lot
of indies avoid 3D.
It's because-- I
mean, especially--
it's getting easier all
the time, especially
with tools like Unity and
Blender but a lot in Indies
do stick to 2D, because
3D just gives you
a lot of hassles that you
don't have to deal with in 2D.
And usually you need more
artists to work with 3D,
because, to make a game in
3D, it takes a long time.
You have to model environments.
You have to model characters.
You have to model objects.
Whereas in a 2D game,
I'd be like all right,
a box is just four lines
and just color it in.
Box in 3D?
All right, I made the cube.
That's easy, whatever.
Now I got to texture it,
and I got to inclusion map
it, normal map it-- It
takes a lot more time.
And it usually ends up
looking really nice,
but usually you'd
need more artists.
The roles in 3D is modeling--
this is one of my earlier
attempts at modeling.
So the modelers, they sculpt
3D characters in environments.
They sculpt what's going
to be put into the world.
Modeling and texturing makes
up the bulk of 3D work.
It takes a long
time to get right,
and then sort of having to
make it work within your game
is another big facet of that.
ZBrush is a really fancy tool
that a lot of 3D artists use.
And they will sculpt the
crap out of it, and be like,
oh man, you can see every--
I sculpted every skin pore
on this guy's face,
and every vein
is actually underneath his skin,
and the fat, and the muscle,
and the bone-- yeah, good luck
getting that to run in any game
right now.
Obviously, things
getting more powerful.
Again, as an indie
guy, if you tried
to sculpt every pore
into a guy's skin,
you're going to end
up spending a month
working on that where you
should have been spending
a month just pumping out art.
So those get broken down further
into character art, which
is-- at bigger studios, you
do have a specific character
artist.
They only work on
the characters,
because the characters
are a very important part
of the game,
obviously, and usually
have to be more detailed
than a lot of the other parts
of the game, especially if
it's the player character.
You're always staring at them
if they're a third person game,
or if they're NPCs you deal
with regularly in the world,
they're always there.
They're always looking at them.
They have to be visually
nice to look at.
And the modelers have
to spend a lot of time
making that work
right and look right.
And they also have to deal
with a lot of uncanny valley
stuff, which-- what
the uncanny valley is,
if you try to make it
realistic, and it doesn't quite
look realistic-- like this
guy-- people look weird,
and people are
weirded out by that.
And it's a big problem character
artists have to deal with.
Environment artists-- they're
the ones who make the world.
They make the buildings.
They make the trees.
They make the mountains.
They're the ones who
fill up the world.
Sometimes concept
artists are actually
broken up between character
artists and environment artists
too, depending on how
big the studio is.
Again, as an indie,
you're always
making the environment art, the
character art, the concept art,
UI, and everything.
But usually when you hand in
a portfolio to a big studio,
as an artist, they
always ask first,
are you a character artist or
are you an environment artist?
Unless you're going
for like UI design.
But as an artist, if
you go up and say,
I don't-- I'm kind of
both-- which is what I do,
kind of both-- they
just turn away.
They don't have time for
you unless you're just
unbelievably amazing at both.
So the big facet I skipped
out on both of those things
is animation, which
pertains to 2D and 3D.
Animation is very,
very difficult
to get right in 2D, and in
3D, but 3D is way easier.
There's a reason Disney closed
down all their 2D animation
studios, because it's
a waste of time now.
It looks good, but it's very
expensive, very time consuming.
A good reference point is--
has anyone played Skullgirls?
Which was like a 2D
indie fighting game.
They wanted to add a single
character to their game.
And they started a Kickstarter
and they asked for $250 grand
just to add one character.
Because of how
exact the animations
had to be and the quality
of the 2D animations.
Hand drawing animations
is very time consuming
for sprites-- and sort of
hand animating 2D guys.
So that was sort of
solved by tweening.
Tweening is-- as you probably
all know-- is I have my arm,
and I draw it, and I
can do this with it.
And that makes
animation more fluid,
and you can sort of
blend in animations
with other animations much
easier, especially with like,
I've been using
Spine-- that's it.
Spine in Unity to help blend a
lot of my tweening animations.
3D usually only works
with tweening animations,
in sort of, you have
the animation rigged.
And you move the
body parts around,
and sort of algorithmically
draws in the in between frames.
Whereas in hand drawn 2D
animation-- old school
2D animation-- characters-- if
you want to move the character
like this, you have to draw
all of those frames usually.
So that's why a lot of indies,
they turn to pixel art.
Because an arm doing this
is like two blocks moving,
which it takes way less time.
It's way easier.
And it's a style
that a lot of people
like so it's sort
of easy to sell it.
If there was no such
thing as pixel art,
and you tried to make
a pixel art game now,
people would be like,
this is kind of lazy.
The whole world was
Disney quality animation.
All right, great, so you're
thinking about what kind
of artists you need, what roles
you need to fill for your game.
But wait!
The most important
thing is, how much money
do you have in your wallet?
Because artists cost
money, obviously.
They have to eat, as much
as the starving artist
stereotype is perpetuated.
Obviously, if
you're a big studio,
you can just throw down
the fat stacks of cash,
and say, I want four
concept artists,
an army of VFX artists,
3D art modelers.
I need 2D texture guys and
UI designers, you name it.
And they can bring
in every one and get
the best of the best,
because they have millions
of dollars to work with.
As an indie, you don't have
anything to work with, usually,
unless you Kickstarted magically
now, and made a ton of money,
or you have some sort
of outside funding,
you sort of have to coax
an artist into your grasp.
And either promise them
with some money you have
or revenue share,
but usually you're
going to only end up with
maybe one, two artists,
depending on the
size of your team.
It's tough.
Amazing artists
cost a lot of money.
If you're trying to go
for the best of the best,
the famous guy you saw
on the internet one time,
they're going to
charge for being
the famous guy on the
internet you saw one time.
Middle-of-the-road artists
are harder to find,
because-- how do I put this--
either they're too old to have
kept going with art
and they've given up,
because they couldn't
be an amazing artist,
and they're not making enough
money as an artist making
a living, and they're
sort of given up,
or you can nab them right
out of school at some point
or in school.
But there are a lot of
crappy artists out there.
If you want to find any
artist, there's a ton of them.
I will go into how to
find those guys too.
First, back to the next-- one
of the early slides here--
artists are important.
I know as a designer programmer,
you think you can do it all,
but don't skimp on artists.
If you have an
amazing game idea,
you want to make that
product the best you can.
And having a really good
artist is a big part of that.
You might think, I'm just going
to sell my game on mechanics.
It's going to be great.
The best mechanics
you've ever seen.
But why stop there?
Why not have amazing art
to go with your mechanics?
If you can hire multiple
artists, please do.
Because it'll take a load
off of them, because--
especially at a big studio,
even indie studios-- making art
is a huge chunk of time.
As graphics get more and
more intense and more
and more realistic,
art is the thing
that takes up the most amount
of time during development
and it's the money sink now.
You know, OK, let's
say we're working
on the new Call of
Duty-- just came out.
All right, this is a
first-person shooter.
We can do some level design.
There's some added features.
But like, all right,
we need robots,
and destructible
buildings, and soldiers,
and everything has to look
as top quality as possible,
or else everyone will decry
the game as looking like crap,
because of one other game
that did go that extra mile.
And as an indie,
maybe you do want
to try and compete with that,
in that-- let's say, all right,
you have your illustrator.
He can do the concept art,
he can do the 2D assets,
in a lot of ways.
But maybe he's not the
best at animation--
I'm not the best at animation--
so we'll get an animator,
as well, who doesn't have to
come up with the cool designs--
maybe he can help
or she can help--
but you have this artist.
You can be like, look, these are
the monsters I need animated.
Can you do the animation while
I move on to the next thing?
And especially if you're working
in 3D, having multiple artists
is almost a must,
because otherwise you're
never really going
to get anything done,
unless you can sort of design
around having one artist, which
becomes a huge limiting factor.
But again, with everything,
especially in game development,
you get sort of a law
of diminishing returns.
The more artists you have-- or
the bigger your team is-- you
know, going back to Destiny with
it's ridiculously high budget.
It was like $300 million
or something, $500 million?
You know, how much
more game did they get?
How much more
entertainment value
did they get with their
like studios of artists?
They didn't just have
one studio of artists
working on that game.
They had multiple.
So if you're an indie studio
and you're like, right,
we have two programmers
and, like, eight artists.
Eight artists, that work
is diluted between them.
You have to try and make
sure that each one of them
is working in the
exact same style.
You have to sort of understand
that it is difficult to switch
your art style.
If you've been drawing
one way your whole life,
and then you're hired to
a team, maybe wrongly,
to work on this game that
looks nothing like anything
you've ever done.
And you can't work within those
limits, within that style,
you're going to
make work that looks
different from the other
artists, and it will stand out
and it'll look weird.
Yes, really.
Artists are important.
I got to really stress this
point because I like work.
Artists not only make
the game look good,
but they inspire the
rest of the team.
If you're just sitting, staring
at blocks hitting-- you know,
pongs-- hitting a block
back and forth all day,
you're going to get
tired of it if you're
working on it for a year.
If you have constant art
coming in, like concept art,
animations, illustrations,
and you see it
when a website writes
about your game,
or a You-Tuber does a
stream about your game,
it's exciting to see like,
look how good my game is,
and I need to make this better
to match to the awesome art
that I have in the game.
It helps motivate everyone to
be excited about the project
they're working on.
To know that, look,
when this comes out,
it's going to look great.
And it's going to be
compared to the best of them.
Because that's awesome!
And everyone should be inspired.
And art is such a quick
way of inspiring people,
that it's almost worth the
money to pay the artist just
to keep your wheels turning.
Because if you just, again,
if you're just watching
blocks bounce back and
forth-- yeah, great, OK.
If you get excited about
that, that's great.
But if you've got five
other people on your team,
and they're all just working on
blocks bouncing back and forth,
they're going to go and work
on something else that's
more interesting.
So where do you find
these so-called artists?
Usually in sewers,
like the Ninja Turtles.
But artists, in general, are
usually introverted people.
Sort of like a
upbringing of-- I'm
just going to sit in the
corner and doodle all the time.
A lot of programmers
have the same thing--
I'm going to sit on
my computer and code.
A lot of them don't go out of
their way to make attention
to themselves.
I first learned
this when I was sort
of going to meet ups around
Boston for game development.
And how few artists
I was meeting.
It was kind of disheartening
in a lot of ways.
And the few artists I was
meeting, a lot of them
were like, eh, OK, get
out of here, you're done.
Because artists, sort of,
even some of the best artists
I know, they sit in their
rooms, they make their art,
maybe they get a blog
post on the internet,
and it does really well.
But a lot of them are
just sort of like,
oh I'll just work
on this drawing.
It's OK.
And it's crap.
Work on the next one.
So you do have to look for
the right artist, which
is sometimes more difficult
than you think it would be.
You would think all artists
are always looking for work.
They're all starving.
They need work.
They need work to live.
Well, yeah sure, a lot of them.
They're not going to be coming
looking for you specifically.
So here's some ideas
of how to track down
this elusive species.
Networking.
Meet-ups, like I mentioned,
a lot of game dev meet-ups.
They do exist.
They are there.
There's some comic
book meet-ups in Boston
with a lot of artists.
It's all about maybe you'll
meet someone who knows someone.
That's how most of
my work comes in,
is someone who knows me from
someone or from a project I
worked on through networking,
they get in contact with me,
and I get work.
I actually used this in a
slide for one of my classes.
This is PAX.
PAX is actually another
great place, surprisingly
to meet other artists.
Because a lot of people
are walking around booths,
looking for work,
surprisingly, at PAX.
Which is kind of weird.
They'll hand you business
cards and you're like,
oh, I'll check out
your portfolio later.
Maybe they're pretty good.
And then maybe there's
something to that.
Obviously, bigger conferences
like GDC, IndieCade,
like Unite, or something.
There's a lot of artists
there that hang out,
and they're a great
place to meet, socialize,
see if you find someone
you sort of can relate to
and hang out with,
and maybe they
have some really cool work
they can make for you.
I just thought it was
funny, because I randomly
found this picture of
PAX East on the internet.
Ziba and I at our first
booth-- we're actually in it--
and it's circled.
Our birth, I was very
excited about that.
Internet, that scary place.
There are a lot of artists
on the internet, obviously.
There are some
big sites that are
great to find artists, and sort
of remotely discuss with them.
CG hub used to be a big
one, but for some reason
the guy just shut it down.
I don't know why.
But deviant art, you have to
shift through a pile of shit
to find good art in
deviant art, but it exists.
Tumblr is actually really good.
A lot of artists I know,
especially good artists,
post their art on Tumblr.
And usually with tags
like game art or concept
art or indie art.
And again, you have the
shift through a lot of crap
to find the good stuff.
But I know a lot of people
who find work through Tumblr.
Conceptart.org has some of the
bigger, well-known artists,
but there's also a lot
of smaller artists.
There's like a jobs board
you can post on there.
This was conceptart.org.
A lot of the big studios
post there, looking for jobs.
This is more for 2D painters,
and concept artists, and 2D
guys more-- Polycount,
for 3D artists,
which is another great
website and resource.
But if you want to scrape the
bottom of the barrel, schools.
Schools are a great way
to get free artists.
I like the claw grabber,
because that's basically
what you're getting.
I mean, I'm not
saying there aren't
amazing artists at school.
Of course there are.
But most of them are,
obviously, inexperienced.
Most of them will work
for cheap to nothing,
because they're just
excited about the fact
to work on a game.
So if you just desperately
need an artist.
And you're just like,
I got this prototype.
I want to pitch
it somewhere else,
but I just need some art in it.
Schools are a great places.
There's lots of schools
in the Boston area.
A lot of art schools
around here with lots
of people looking
for work, obviously.
But again, scraping the
bottom of the barrel.
There's a lot of shows that
aren't about games where
are great to pick up artists.
In Boston, we have the
Massachusetts Independents
Comics Expo, where a bunch
of artists sit around tables
and they sell their comics.
This is a great place to meet
artists who, maybe, aren't
into games, but maybe you
find someone who's like wow,
your style's really unique.
Your style's really cool.
Come work for me.
Come be a part of my team
and we can make something
really interesting together.
There's a lot of
artists' tables.
There's a lot of-- I
used to do these a lot.
I don't really do
them so much anymore,
but-- just selling
your prints on tables.
There's lots of
festivals all the time.
I know this isn't really
a stereotypical where
to find a game artist,
but they are great places
to find artists who maybe never
thought about making games.
And maybe they have
a really cool style
that'll fit games perfectly, but
they've just never even thought
about it.
Because, again, in this
very competitive environment
that we are in,
game development,
you want to make your games
stand out and be unique.
You don't want it
to look like, again,
Call of Duty number five.
Why are you bothering
at that point?
Why don't you find someone
who has like-- no one
can draw like this person.
It might not be
the most realistic,
and it might not be
the theme of the time--
like low poly is
a big thing now--
but like, this guy
will stand out.
This guy will make my game look
so unique and so interesting
to people who may not have even
been interested in my mechanics
in the first place.
And it jives with my theme.
I want this person
to work for me
to make my game
the best it can be,
because that's really
what it's about.
It's all about finding
that special someone.
You're going to have a
working relation together.
You're going to have
some rough times,
you're going to have
some good times together.
So you really want to
find someone, especially
as an artist, who you guys
can work together very well.
You understand a common goal.
You're going to be
both-- or if you
have multiple artists-- you're
going to be all your harshest
critics, including themselves.
You're going to-- because
if no one in your group
is telling you what
you're doing is bad,
then everyone else will and.
They will do it much
harsher and much meaner
than anybody in your group.
Because if you're like,
hey man, you know, this
is a good drawing,
but why don't you
try doing this to
make it better,
is much better than
a comment on, like,
[? Kotaki ?] was saying,
this fucking sucks.
Don't buy this
fucking piece of shit.
Because that's-- yeah.
You want to, again, you
want to find someone
who's good as an artist.
You want to find
someone who's competent,
who turns things in on
time-- which is a big thing.
I've recommended
too many artists
to developer friends who did
not turn things in on time,
and that made me look
bad in a lot of ways,
because I recomm-- I thought
these-- I'm like these guys are
great.
They work hard.
But they weren't
hitting their deadlines,
they weren't getting stuff
in, so they obviously
lost those contracts.
So you guys are really going
to be like partners in crime,
especially if you're in
a small, two-man group.
So these are some my working
relationships I'll talk about.
Girls Like Robots, I
developed with Ziba.
He's up there.
You can all look
at him if you want.
He took a chance on me.
I was out of college.
And I'd done my three
month period of mourning
looking for a job.
And he found me and said,
OK, you're OK enough.
I'll let you work on my game.
And so we really hit it off.
And we worked really
well together.
This game went places we didn't
think it was going to go,
which was great.
It's still doing
things that I didn't
think it could do as a game.
And so we've continued to
work together from this.
This was The Counting Kingdom
with Little Worlds Interactive,
Jenna Hoffstein.
This was a more standard
contractual artist hiring,
game development cycle.
Jenna came to me and was like,
I need these five things.
Done.
I need these 10 things.
I need these five things.
Done.
All done with
[? sculpture ?] works
and work for hire contracts.
She is the most
efficient game designer
I've ever met in my life.
It was just boom,
boom, boom, boom.
We're aiming for this release.
Done.
Released.
It was kind of amazing.
I don't think any
other game I've ever
seen in my life
developed that smoothly.
And she didn't do any coding,
which was also the crazy thing,
as the lead designer and coder.
She only used PlayMaker,
which was kind of fascinating.
Elegy for a Dead
World was a weird
in that I worked with Ziba
again from Popcannibal,
but this was a game jam game
that turned into a full game
when it started
getting some attention.
It started out as a
rev share agreement
between a few different
studios in the office.
And it's been,
less of, these are
my boss's working on the
game, but I've sort of been
like a partner in crime.
I'm on the same level as
all the designers, which is
kind of interesting for once.
All right, enough of that.
Great, you found an artist.
Now what do you do with them?
You have them, all right?
You just going to
poke 'em a little bit?
Hey, make some art.
Well, first you
have to hire them.
And there's one way I like
to think that artists should
be hired is with an art test.
Before you sign them up for
a huge massive contract,
you should say
look, you know what?
Your portfolio looks great.
I really like you as a person.
I think we're going to
work really well together.
But how about you like take
this design that I did,
and I want to see
the final product.
And I want to see how
long it takes you.
I want to understand your
workflow and your process.
Because they might have the most
amazing portfolio in the world,
but if it takes
them three months
to draw a single picture,
then it's not worth your time.
And maybe they just lied.
That's always a thing.
They might have just been like,
I just found this picture.
I found a photo
and I drew over it,
which a lot concept artists
do to get things done quickly.
They maybe can't do what
you think they can do,
and this is a good way to figure
out exactly what they can do.
So you do pay them for this.
You pay them for their time,
whether you hire them or not.
How many art tests I've
gotten, which were like,
oh no, no, I'm not going to
pay you for the art tests,
because it's just an art test.
I want to see if I
want to hire you.
No, no, no.
They took time out
of their schedule,
doesn't matter if
they're busy or not,
to make this art
test to show they
are capable of doing the work.
You pay them for
the time they spent
on it, whether they continue
to work for you or not.
If they don't, you say,
thank you for your time.
I don't think you're exactly
what we're looking for.
Get lost.
But you do pay them
for their time.
Contracting, most
indies are going
to be on work-for-hire basises
for independent artists.
What I mean by work-for-hire,
those of you who don't know,
any work they make,
they don't own anymore.
When I draw a picture on
my own, it is my copyright.
I can do whatever
I want with it.
I can hire a 70 foot
billboard and put it up,
and there's nothing
anybody can do about it.
But if I'm under a
work-for-hire contract,
and I'm working for a game
designer or game company,
and I make art for
that game, I longer
can put it up on a
70 foot billboard
without any permissions.
The company, or the designer, or
the person I'm working for now
owns that art.
And that is what most
artists and other people
work as for game companies.
In art school, I was always told
work-for-hire contracts aren't
fair, because then I
can't sell my art again.
And that is a-- I mean,
that's good as an artist,
meaning like, good, I
can sell my same painting
again and again and again
and again for lots of money,
and make more money off
of this one painting.
But that's not the
norm in game industry.
It's the norm in other illus--
in other illustration fields
you can do that-- some
magazine publishing.
Since they're all dying,
they're much more lenient
on that thing, on that.
But game companies is,
you no longer own the art.
So you're going to have to
make a work-for-hire contract,
usually with a scope of work
attached to it of what exactly
is needed from the artist.
Another interesting point
for independent contractors
when hiring for work-for-hire
work is software licensing.
It's usually up to the artist
to have their own software.
If they're hired full-time--
if you somehow magically
are able to do that, usually
you have to supply the software,
especially for
working at an office.
Great, so you've hired them.
You've got them down.
They're sitting there.
They've got their tablet out.
They got their pen.
Now what do you do?
You got to art direct them.
You have to play art director,
even if you can't draw.
As the person who
hired this artist,
you have to critique them,
and understand how they work,
and to give them feedback
constantly, even if it's just
encouragement.
You have to make them
make the art that you
want them to make for you.
They're not making
art for themselves,
they're making art for you.
They're not fine artists.
Fine artists just sort
of waft in the air
and discover what they want.
But as an illustrator, or a 3D
artist, you're like a plumber.
I need you to fix this pipe.
I need you to draw this
picture specifically.
It's a great variation
on do what I say,
not what I do, especially with
a programmer or designer who
can't draw.
But here are some helpful
things to yell at artists.
Aesthetic, just instead of
saying do it better this time,
just not as crap.
Aesthetic, the general
feel of the art.
This one is a little hard
to critique, aesthetic,
but if you have a
general sense of what
the theme of the game
you're going for, definitely
be like, all right, this
is a zombie shooter.
OK, you've put
Hello Kitty in here.
This isn't really the aesthetic
I'm looking for in the game.
And that ties into style.
They're very close together,
but style is very easier
to point to and be like, we're
looking for this style of game.
And that helps guide the artist.
OK, that's what
they're thinking.
It's a bad idea, but I'll
sort of work with it,
and see what I can come up with.
Contrast is probably the
most important term in art,
in general, and specifically
for game development art.
Contrast is how different
things look, like in contrast
in real life.
Like when two things
contrast against each other,
that you're telling the
difference between them
or the similarities.
In games, you want the
character to stand out
from the background.
You need items to be obvious.
You need certain things to
stand out more than others,
maybe things to disappear
more than others, maybe things
to be more similar,
to be more hidden.
Like if you're making a Metal
Gear Solid game is like, oh,
I need the character to
blend into the environment.
Contrast is a very
helpful word when
you're having trouble defining
what's wrong with this image,
why isn't it
working in the game?
OK, it's because these
animations blend in too much
with the character animations.
I can't tell what's going on.
Or, this image, there's
not enough depth in it.
This image, I need more depth.
Contrast is a big word.
It's a really great word
that helps with that.
Saturation is another handy
one, but that just means how
colourful something is.
The more saturated something is,
the more vibrant and colorful
it is.
The less saturated it is,
the more gray into whites
and blacks it is.
That really helps with
saying, all right,
this is sort of the objects
and the theme I'm going for,
but why don't you
make it more colorful?
Maybe make it more saturated
so the world feels more
fantastical and interesting.
Or, it's like I want
this to be dark and grim.
Let's lower the
saturation quite a bit
to really make it feel
like oh, it's a gray day
and it's dark and dreary.
Composition, just the layout of
art, and the layout of levels,
or the layout of what
the player is seeing,
what the player is dealing with.
It's just sort of the
arrangement of items.
It's another handy word to know.
But of course,
encouragement, encouragement
is always needed in any
part of game development.
It's always great to hear
you're doing a good job.
Give yourself a high-five,
or me a high-five, whatever.
It's really helpful to
encourage your artists,
so it makes them make
the best work they can.
If you're just yelling
at them all the time,
and they're not doing a good
job-- or you don't think
they're doing a good job.
Maybe they aren't,
but they're not
going to get better if you're
just always dissing what
they've got, and it's not fun.
Let's go into-- so
you've got the artist,
you're going to art direct
them, now what are the phases?
Pre-production!
Pre-production is the happiest
part of game development.
You're coming up
with all the ideas.
Your scope is increasing
through the roof.
You're like, oh, now we're
going to have open world this.
The world's dynamic,
the characters
die, their families grow
up, it's going to be great.
The art is going
to be realistic!
It's going to go into space!
We got to have all
these textures!
And the concept art is amazing!
But as an artist, you're
working on, usually,
the concept art for the game.
You're helping with
ideas sometimes.
Maybe your designer,
he's so happy
to let you help out
with ideas for the game.
Pitches, another good thing
if you're making concept art.
If you're pitching a
game to get funding,
like Kickstarter
or maybe it's one
of the bigger studios like Sony,
Microsoft, Nintendo, or others.
If you're trying to
get money upfront,
artwork really helps a pitch,
because you have nothing
to show.
On Kickstarter, you're
selling hopes and dreams.
You're not selling a game.
Because people are
imagining in their
heads what the actual
game is going to be,
and it's way better than what
you're actually going to make,
because they have no idea
what they're thinking about.
Pitches with art work better
than pitches with nothing.
If you just have text,
and just be like,
here's some scribbles of
how my game's going to work.
They're going to be
like, I'm not excited.
But if you have like,
here's a painting!
And then they're like, wow!
That's amazing!
How's the game going to work?
Don't worry about that.
Just look at the painting.
Web stuff, so making a
website, obviously, it's
early pre-production.
Maybe you want to make a blog
or something about your game.
It's a great place to start.
And posting about
art as it comes in
from concept art, and pictures--
Logos are another
big thing, especially
if you're doing a pitch.
Logos really help with
identifying your game,
not only to your
selves, but if you ever
want to talk about
it really early on,
it's a really good way of
getting your icon out there.
And early prototype work, so
if you've made a prototype,
and you're like, look, let's
just slap some art in there
to see what this game's actually
going to visually feel like.
This is all part
of pre-production.
Production, the
bulk of the work.
So this is all the
asset creation.
This is, maybe, you're
doing concept art here too.
Maybe you've said, all right,
that style isn't working.
Let's go back a
little bit, but we'll
keep moving forward with
making models and texturing.
It's all about iterations
too in production.
It's sort of oh, OK, this
level doesn't quite look right.
Let's change it a little bit.
Let's make it look like this.
This is the longest
part of game design
usually, unless your
pre-production was,
I've thought of this
game from five years ago.
This is just making
the stuff that
will actually go in the game
and making it fit together.
Near end of production, and
this is when you start panicking
and realize your open world
space game with dynamic NPCs
and families that live
and die and have children
isn't exactly panning out.
You start cutting things
just to get things done.
The artist is usually hopefully
done by now towards the end,
but they have to start
doing the promotional push.
They have to start
making the illustrations,
and the art, and
the graphic designs,
and the Steam banners,
and making sure everything
looks as best as it can so
when this game fires out
to the world, a lot
of people get it.
As indies, I have to
make trailers too.
Usually you have a trailer
dude for that at a big studio,
but as indies, usually the
artist has to make the trailer.
So that takes up more
time you would think.
On The Counting Kingdom,
Jenna came to me and said,
I need a trailer in two weeks.
And that was harrowing
because I fully
animated it for some reason.
But a lot of the art is
also like putting together
store assets like trailers and
banners and promotional stuff.
So sort of in conclusion, indie
artists, they fill many roles.
They do lots of things.
At a big studio, you have
these very specific jobs
that everyone is assigned.
They go in the
morning and they know,
I'm going to be the
guy who animates
shattering glass all day.
And they do it for three years
and the Avengers comes out.
But at a smaller studio,
you know, all right, I'm
doing the concept
art, at the same time,
learning how to model
it, at the same time,
I'm figuring out how
the items in the game
are going to work,
at the same time,
making the logo and maybe
some early illustration
promotional arts.
And you have to like balance
a lot of these things.
So is this is me in my zen
drawing state, I feel like.
I don't usually get to that.
I usually get really angry
and I don't get this calm
when it comes to that.
But yeah, indie artists, they
have so much stuff to do,
they have so much
stuff to offer.
Hire artists.
Don't make your game
without an artist.
That's boring.
If you think you
can do it yourself,
that's great, but
artists, they add a lot.
They inspire you.
They usually work hard if
you find the right one.
And you can form long-term
meaningful partnerships
with them and it's great.
Thank you.
There's my email address and
my website, if anybody cares.
[APPLAUSE]
Cool.
44 minutes.
It was close.
SPEAKER 1: Excellent.
Do you got time for questions?
LUIGI GUATIERI: Sure.
Nothing?
Really?
[INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: Actually,
quick question.
LUIGI GUATIERI: There you go.
AUDIENCE: Do you ever work on
multiple projects [INAUDIBLE].
LUIGI GUATIERI: I usually
work on multiple projects
at the same time.
I guess that was a good point.
I need to bring up--
that was a good question.
As a indie artist, I'm not
getting paid a lot of money.
End of story.
It doesn't happen.
So usually I have to work
on more than one project
at the same time just
to let ends meet.
Usually the work isn't full-time
because either the company
can't afford to
have it full-time,
or the amount of work
they need isn't full-time.
You have to juggle
a lot as an artist.
I'm working on a
couple projects,
doing contract work, sort
of freelance illustration
on the side.
I'm also teaching a class.
And you have to juggle all
these things at once to survive,
basically.
Because as sad as it sounds,
indie games don't make a lot
of money usually, unless
[? you're at ?] Goat Simulator.
Yes, go!
AUDIENCE: I didn't quite
catch what you said,
2D animation is harder
than 3D animation.
LUIGI GUATIERI: Have you ever
seen an old Disney movie?
They usually had
armies of what they
called in-betweeners, in that
there would be a key frame
artist.
He would draw Snow
White dancing like this.
And then there would
be the poor bastards
who had to draw every
single frame of her going
like this, all 30 or 40 frames.
So in a game, if you want
hand-drawn animations that
look really
interesting and nice,
you have to get someone
who will bother.
Like, Street Fighter III
is a great exam-- or King
of Fighters-- those games
take forever to animate,
because they are
done in that Disney
style, in terms of
just frame by frame
by frame by frame by frame.
But the other thing
they have to worry about
is to make sure that the hit
points are in the right place,
that the collision boxes
are in the right place.
It takes a lot of
time to do that.
That's why when I
mentioned tweening
as a quick way of
trying to mimic that,
it doesn't look as good usually.
And in a lot of games that
use a lot of tweening,
like Limbo, for example, they
hide it with silhouettes.
Because you get these
weird seams and it
doesn't look as good.
There are obviously tools
that help with this like Flash
animation.
You can sort of do an in-between
of tweening and hand animation.
But sort of frame by
frame, sprite animation,
takes a long time.
And 3D-- I mean, it's
easier, because it's all
tweening usually.
Unless you have some character
that transforms all the time.
It's the same way in 2D,
in that a 3D arm that
is rigged like this
is always going
to look like this because you
can just sort of manipulate it
in 3D space.
Doing this in 3D is really easy.
Doing this in 2D takes forever,
if you know what I mean.
That answer your question?
AUDIENCE: Kind of.
LUIGI GUATIERI:
Is there something
you need me to follow up on?
AUDIENCE: I kind of
see what you mean,
like you have to
draw every frame.
LUIGI GUATIERI: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Unity has a very
cool way to go around this.
Like, [INAUDIBLE] that's
actually 3D that is snap-shot
into 2D, so they
don't have to worry--
LUIGI GUATIERI: Yeah,
that's one way to do it.
That's one way to
solve it, but then you
have to make all your
models in 3D first,
and then animate in 3D, which
the modeling process takes time
as well.
And then you have to
think about-- all right,
I have 2D artists.
Can I do this?
No, I need a 3D
artist to do this.
It's just something
to think about.
But yeah, that's a way around
it that a lot of people use.
Yes, go.
AUDIENCE: Does it make sense
for a software engineer
to learn the basics of
drawing, so that they better
understand maybe the artists
and give more reasonable tasks?
LUIGI GUATIERI: Sorry, could
you repeat the question?
AUDIENCE: So does it make
sense for a software engineer
to learn the basics of drawing,
so that you better understand
artists and maybe give
more reasonable tasks?
LUIGI GUATIERI: Yes.
Programmers, designers, software
engineers should totally
try to understand the basics
of art and color theory
and the process of making
art, so when it comes time
to either advising the artist
on what they need to change
or what might not fit, you
have some understanding
of all right, these
colors go together.
These colors don't go together.
Could you composition
this a little better,
so you like put these down
here and that over there.
But again, a lot of art
direction is about contrasting,
and composition, and
color is a big one.
I didn't really talk about
color, color theory, too much.
Like for instance, Jenna in
Little Worlds Interactive,
when I worked with
her, she already
had a pretty good graphic design
sense, which really helped in,
when I gave her
art, and the sort
of feedback she could give me.
And also when she
utilized my art.
So I didn't put
anything into that game.
I wasn't directly working in
Unity on The Counting Kingdom.
She knew how things
look good together,
just because she'd already
had like a background in web
design.
So yes.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: You were saying
earlier that usually it's
good to have-- or it's
basically a must to have--
different people specialized
in different roles.
Like, someone is
the game designer,
someone's a programmer,
and then you
have to find artists
to do all the game art.
Do you ever find
outliers to that?
Like, exceptions?
Like, someone who does
everything and still
comes up [INAUDIBLE]?
LUIGI GUATIERI: Of course,
there's always exceptions.
There's always some magic
man who can do it all,
or magic woman.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
LUIGI GUATIERI: An example of
an artist who can do it all.
AUDIENCE: Like, a game.
LUIGI GUATIERI: A
game designer who
can do it all-- I don't know.
Can you name anyone?
AUDIENCE: Other than
[? Dwarf Fortress? ?]
LUIGI GUATIERI:
[? Dwarf Fortress, ?] yes.
I mean, a lot of
game designers--
especially if they do
it as a hobby-- they
make their own stuff.
They make their own art.
It's just a good idea
to spread the work out,
because as an indie--
and obviously,
a lot of my developer
friends-- they
have to focus so much of
their time on marketing,
and programming, and designing,
that, to also add art to that,
you've just extended your game
development cycle by a lot.
And maybe you're not
as competent in that.
And people are more
apt at telling bad art
than they are from
telling bad game design.
Because all you need
to be able to see
is just a picture of the game
or video from the game and go,
that doesn't look very good.
Even if the viewer
doesn't understand
why it doesn't look good, they
can tell that immediately.
I don't like that.
So if the designer, programmer
is confident enough,
yeah, more power to them.
But you're going to be putting
a lot to work on yourself.
And you're not going
to get your game done
in a timely fashion at all.
And it probably won't
be the best you can do.
AUDIENCE: Can I ask
one more question?
LUIGI GUATIERI: Sure.
AUDIENCE: Do you
ever as an artist
think about designing
a video game?
Do you ever think about
making [INAUDIBLE] video game?
Like, [INAUDIBLE]?
LUIGI GUATIERI: So I work
with a few developers now.
And I'm always giving
my design ideas.
I always have ideas for games.
I love coming up
with ideas for games.
I don't think I would
call myself apt enough
to design the whole
game by myself yet,
so I'm definitely still focused
on the art side of things.
But yeah, I love
designing games.
It's fun.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: What have you
had to do for an art test?
LUIGI GUATIERI: So
usually for an art test,
it depends on the game.
So I recently did an art test
for some sort of mobile MOBA
game, and what they
asked-- they said
here are your
character descriptions,
design these characters.
And I said, all right, that'll
take me this amount of time.
They said, great, that's fine.
This is my rate.
It was a quick contract.
Out the door for that.
And I designed the characters.
I didn't end up
getting the work,
but I don't think
my style was really
what they were looking for.
But yeah, it was that.
I designed the characters.
I did a quick turnaround.
So it was like,
characters standing
this way, this way, this
way, this way, from the back,
of each character.
I fully painted one of them,
and said, this is what I got.
I think that's a
pretty good art test,
especially if you're building
a game focused on characters.
If you're building a
game focused environments
be like, draw this
mountain for me that I'm
describing in this text.
So usually an art test is
here's a description, draw this,
especially for an illustrator
or a concept artist.
It's not so much here's a quick
doodle I did, make it better.
It's usually here is a paragraph
of text, make this thing exist.
I feel like that's a
pretty solid art test.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: You
talked about finding
someone who has the style
that you're looking for?
LUIGI GUATIERI: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Is that generally
the case with artists,
or are there artists who
are more flexible in style?
LUIGI GUATIERI: So I like
to think I'm more flexible.
I didn't used to work on a lot
of cute games, but now I do.
That's just what happened.
There are definitely
artists who more-- so I'm
going to go back to art
school here a little bit.
This is time travel.
And I'm going to remind
myself of what my Illustrator
professors told me, is
to never do anything
else other than your style.
Get really good
at that one thing.
And don't bother
with anything else,
because you need to be
the best at what you do.
And I was like,
eh, that's boring.
Most artists have their
style they work in.
A lot of video
game artists, they
go for the hyper-realism
concept art--
the art movie, books, that
you see from VFX houses.
That's why a lot of them can
work together in big groups,
because they all have a
very similar kind of like,
we're going for
realism, robots, tanks.
OK, we can all work together.
The more unique your style
is, I think, the more time
you have to spend
working on that style.
And the more reason, if this
person's style is very unique,
you're hiring them for their
style, not their art talents.
Again, that's why a
lot of big studios,
they hire people
who can do realism,
because that's a little bit
more malleable in terms of what
they can turn that into.
But if you're hiring artists
for their very specific,
unique style, you're getting
them for that one task.
But again, it depends
on the contract for me.
If I'm-- all right, this
is for children's magazine.
I'm not going to put the bad guy
from Doom in there, obviously.
That doesn't make sense.
As an artist, I say
yes to almost every job
that comes my way,
because I don't know when
the next one's going to come.
That's just how it works.
But that's how I work.
A lot of other
people are different.
All right, is that it?
Thank you very much.
It was awesome.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER 1: All right,
so take five minutes
to get with your teams.
If you'd like to have them
take a look at your work,
just have your computer set
aside, close to the edge
so they can easily see it.
And at 2:10, we'll
walk around and see
who wants some feedback
on their games from Luigi.
LUIGI GUATIERI: Cool.
[CHATTER]